peter parker can't save everyone but in
spider-man no way home one peter parker
gets himself a second chance peter
parker aka spider-man is one marvel
character who is as defined by his love
interests as his powers he has had some
of the most iconic girlfriends in all of
marvel comics from mj watson to gwen
stacy peter sure is one lucky fella and
that's not even getting into his various
flings with black cat aka felicia hardy
anytime the web slinger receives a new
big screen adaptation a big question on
everyone's mind is which of his
girlfriends will be present in the film
you're wrong about us being on different
paths we're not on different paths
through my path
then you're always going to be my best
the newest version of the character
played by tom holland got a reboot to
his romantic life with 2017's spider-man
homecoming initially peter parker has a
crush on classmate liz but things get
pretty complicated when it turns out
that her dad is a villain known as
vulture by the time spider-man far from
home rolls around we watch as peter
finally starts going out with michelle
jones aka mj their relationship reaches
a new level in spider-man no way home
when they officially become a couple but
being spider-man's girlfriend comes with
more than the perk of dating a superhero
as mj quickly learns it often means
getting put in harm's way too during the
climactic no way home battle against
electro sandman and lizard mj finds
herself in a position many of
spider-man's girlfriends have
encountered before left to fend for
herself on a tall structure as her
boyfriend battles villains mj falls off
and plummets toward what appears to be
certain death but then something
interesting happens that's bound to give
fans a sense of deja vu arguably one of
the most definitive moments of andrew
garfield's tenure as spider-man is when
he fails to catch gwen stacy as she
falls down a clock tower while he fights
harry osborne in the amazing spider-man
2. the death of gwen stacy is a major
event in marvel comics that is
translated to become an equally major
on-screen event that likely caused more
than one audience member to shed a tear
back in 2014. the event caused
garfield's spider-man to temporarily
hang up the suit and stop being the
friendly neighborhood hero the city
needed he comes back around to fighting
rhino by the end of the film but it's
clear from his most recent appearance
that he's still not quite over gwen's
death just yet when tom holland's peter
parker is at his lowest the garfield
variant lets him know about how he lost
his girlfriend some time ago he doesn't
go into detail but we the audience know
who he's referring to we know this is a
spider-man haunted by his mistakes and
when a similar moment transpires in no
way home he doesn't throw away the
opportunity to prevent history from
repeating itself when mj falls off the
statue of liberty hull and spider-man
jumps to save her but is stopped short
by green goblin fortunately garfield's
spider-man sees what's happening and
leaps into action he catches mj allowing
her to land safely on the ground the
scene lingers on the superhero for a
beat letting the audience really take in
what's happened he may not have been
able to save gwen but he prevented
another spider-man from losing the
person he loves most
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
spiderman no way homer coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you